previously on moors we had arrived yet  our journey was just beginning we've  been gone I took command Mars fought us  every step of the way  they say science and faith don't mix if  they fail I don't care how much you  invested we're out but when everything  is telling you you already lost  if they fail everyone's out there's  nothing you can do but believe we  ignored this horizontal entrance because  it was clogged with breakdown debris so  we made one more leap into the darkness  hey is he easy  we'll be there was some light at the  bottom of the abyss  the idea that one of the lava tubes  could be connected to a tectonic cave is  brilliant we're deploying the dam the  flag is planted it's official humankind  has a home on Mars